俺は今、こんな姿になってしまった…
身動きも取れないし、
体も黒い。
俺はこの先、どーすればいいんだ！…
ﾁﾘｯﾁﾘﾘﾘﾘﾋﾖﾋﾖﾋﾖﾋﾖ…
…ん？
昨日ゲーセンで取った猫でｽ~
デブ。
はいとゆーわけでいよいよ本格的に寒くなってきましたぁ～
秋です。ぅわぁ！
僕の、所沢
こちらですね。
球体（スフィア）モードから解禁されてやっとあの本来の姿に戻ったんですけどもぉ
この所沢、見てわかる通り…
全裸です。
所沢は全裸でね、この冬をひょっとしたら乗り切んなきゃ
いけなくなるので、僕はかわいそうだと思ったわけなんですよ
そこで！（はじめDV）
今回、所沢の為にちょっとねぇ
うちのマミーが服を準備してくれたらしいですw
最初マミーもなんか、ぁぁ//あんなでけぇクマ買って絶対邪魔になるだけだろ。みたいな
チョットこう…Disから入ってたんですけど、
なんかやっぱりね、ちょっと所沢の可愛さにヤラれたみたいで
愛着が湧いたっぽいのかなぁ?
ほら、良かったな。（はじめDV）
これで冬は寒くないぞぉ
ﾊｧｯ//
わぁすごﾌｧ
まじじゃん!
くまモンじゃん!
デっっか!
これが多分ズボンかなぁ?
5L!　5Lです!
わぁスゴいちゃんと縫ってあるんだ!
こっちが上ですね!
こっちが上の服で、
こっちが所沢のズボンになります
ちょ僕が履いてみましょう
（サービスショット）
今回は、この所沢をね
やっぱ冬乗り切らせるために、
服を！…
着てあげようかと思います…(?)
ではいこう!
まずは、とりあえずズボンから履かせていきましょう
フツーに足ぶっこいの入んのかねぇ
BGM「くまの歌」♪
ちゃんと入る!
ちゃんと入るぞ!
ケツがちゃんと入るか分かんないな…/
ちょ、所沢後ろ
ｸｯ…//
なんかエロいね//(笑)
ぇ、エロくはないけどなw
ケツがでかすぎるぞ!
あ、イケそうでも、
バチコぉ～～い！！
多分所沢のズボンは、ちゃんと入ったっぽいすね
ちゃんとズボンは、、入りました!
良かったな!（はじめDV）
所沢の上着を着せていこうと思います
はぁ……はぁ…
腕が通るかかが、大事ですからね
あ、通った
で、回り込んで、
こっち側に入るかどうかだな…
イケるか
腕がもう、、
複雑骨折だからねww
これきたんじゃない??
入った!!
うわあ!入った!入った!
イケるんじゃね?これぇ?
首元が、、
ここが厳しいな、、
ここが、、
首が、、ありすぎて、、
ボタン…厳しくねぇかな…??
第一ボタンが厳しいな…
これ無理じゃなイカ??
これダメだ…多分
第一ボタンとか止まんないよ…
所沢ｧ…
首回りが…
太いな…w
所沢これ無理だよぅ…
ここまでしか出来ないや
なんかこれ以上やると、首が閉まって死んでしまう
ぃぃ一応着れましたが…
………
（はじめDV）
はい、とゆーわけで
ちょっと、ころもぅ
所沢が寒いと思ったので
服を準備させたんですけどぉ…
ちょっとサイズが、、小さかったかな。
まぁでもこれで、ちょっとは寒くないと思うんで
所沢も冬は快適に過ごせそうですね(^▽^)/
良かったなぁ
ダニもなんとか退治出来たんで
これからもちょっと、、
よろしくお願いしま～す(=ﾟωﾟ)ﾉ
じゃあな！